what is exciting welcome back to the
production blog red pill production vlog
man we've done we did casting calls this
week yes in the last three days last
three days three days of casting calls
and it has been fantastic lots of
variation lots of lots of really good
really good stuff and in fact it it was
so inspiring there was so much good
stuff so inspiring so many so many great
great auditions that it gave us some
ideas and we made some tweaks to the the
script and the Meisel sin yes in order
to incorporate some inspiring
performances so much in the same way
that the character of Jesse did not die
at the end of season 1 of Breaking Bad
because Aaron Paul's performance was so
good we're adapting we're adapting we're
adapting these performances these these
auditions were so good that we are we
are adapting to include additional
performances yeah I think the key
element from day one about this core
concept was that we used the word video
portrait so essentially Dan and I kind
of just finished the auditions and then
we thought of what if we had more of
them in it and we'd like cut it together
and have different different phases as
our character box and then we kind of
just had more discussion you know roll
nighter rated iterated and then we're
just kind of what if they're just part
of it yeah like what if they're part of
the portrait so they each have their own
space in it and the core concept of what
we're trying to portray about red pill
kind of mentality still is me
hey if anything I think it's more
enhanced yeah
and this also actually had solved a
problem a a minor problem that had been
something that would be in considering
which was you know how do you fill out
so you've got it you have the set and
you've got the composition of it and we
had the core idea and we had a bunch of
elements elements for it but there were
a few things where we're like well I'm
not really sure what we're gonna put
there but that's a minor detail so we'll
get around to that when we've got bigger
things like location locked it down you
know you gotta you gotta take decisions
one at a time we like prop masters you
figure it out for us like we're you know
that's why we're hiring you is for your
your creative contribution to this
project and this was like wait that's
what we did we did we this gives us
something to do with that space like hey
remember that empties with let's put
this in there and then but it also adds
more contextual kind of yeah about the
philosophy of right pill followings and
yeah the Brotherhood it was it was a
great it was a it was a great little all
sort of creative moments and I think I I
think I I'm excited to mention it
because it it demonstrates the sort of
the the the fluid process the fluid
nature of the creative process well and
I think this is the best part to is that
you never I'm not saying it's a bad way
of filmmaking but if you lock yourself
down to certain expectations or certain
rules then you kind of eliminate the
ability to expand your project to
whatever comes your way yeah it's like
I'm unless you just happen to be Stanley
Kubrick then chances are and even even
this so if you if you want to go full
totalitarian where you're like no I'm
Kubrick I am the next Kubrick I am going
to like everything will be according to
my plan then chances are good that one
you're not Stanley Kubrick and - you
overestimate even
the like genius of Kubrick's ideas right
because you know like you look at it
critically not everything like his works
are not perfect no they're very good he
is he is a phenomenal he was a
phenomenal filmmaker but like think of
how many Kubrick movies you just kind of
go like oh yeah there's that part you
know there's that sequence that goes on
too long there's that decision that
doesn't really make a lot of sense and
you know yes he was able to accomplish
amazing things by being just a complete
totalitarian but at the same time how
many how many rough patches could have
been smoothed over if he opened himself
more to the creative contributions of
his team well and that's the the idea of
his perfectionism was from his
perspective yeah right and ultimately
art is based on your perspective like
it's not gonna be interpreted the same
way for everyone and that's I think in
very important aspect you consider when
you're being a filmmaker yeah that's
just my view and then some people don't
agree with that and that's totally fine
too let's see uh incurring project terms
what else has gone on this week on
location we badly thrown in the line and
we found a bite yeah thank you so much
to to Steve our our project manager rpm
we we put him in charge of getting that
location locked down and it's not it's
not locked yet but we're finally we we
have someone on the other end willing to
start having a communication yeah yeah
in fact they're we're going we're gonna
go see the space like they're extras is
like yeah coming down and see the space
and so if they're at that point where
they're letting us like come into the
space and look at it yeah then unless
they either completely misunderstood our
budget or the space is actually like
leaking like you know it's probably
gonna be you like basically at this
point at this point with the timelines
and whatnot
if we can afford the space and there's
no over problems it's our space yeah
and again this is not to bash MTM like
in any way shape or form they just have
a priority with unfair yeah we actually
we found out what the production was and
it's kind of like in retrospect it's
like oh I don't blame ya compressing us
off yeah so again we will probably
actually be renting from MTM so all
they're like they're PvE dolly and their
track and their lights and stuff like
they don't like to go talk to them about
that yet however to you the dolly
because they've only got I think
wonderfully the pee-wee's if not there's
also a production house in the city
called William F White's and then we'll
approach them after MTM it and if they
don't have a peewee dolly then we're
boned well then then we just then we
make do with the doorway yeah then we
which is not preferred it's not
preferred but it is doable yeah
we've used them a lot which is why we
would rather use a peewee we want to
step up step up you know at the at the
very bottom like at the at the and the
sort of dead end option is that we end
up with just the what is it the Dana
dolly where it's just the plan yeah and
then you would have known or tripod on
top of it and you're wrapping it down
with with quick I'm making an executive
decision right now that will not be
allowed to happen over set it's just
flat-out no I will pay you car go
straight we just cargo strap it down you
know we've been there done that we did
that on waited hey we did that on on one
hit die and it turned out it just takes
three hours to set up and get it stable
great we don't got time for this we
don't we don't want our grips to have a
what was it is 5:30 6:00 a.m. calls
again executive producer decision no
producer
No okay what else oh we are in talks
with our construction crew don't build
our set and also do our props for us
hopefully Mike is his name and he and a
bunch of his pal I don't know who they
are I think they're his friends but they
own a shop together and fabrication shop
fabrication shop and they are going to
be meeting with dad and most likely
Steve as I might be in town by then to
go over all those plans make sure the
measurements are correct and start
talking about the actual look of the set
and whether to make it look the way you
envisioned it to be I'm seriously
thinking Shade carpet for the floor
well shag I was I was thinking more it
it's like a mute Brown yes like a beige
yeah purple yeah no no I don't think
they fabricate that anymore
purple shag shake I'd keep the leftovers
and just like redo my house HQ and Beach
cute yep okay what else what else can we
talk about yeah no I think that's pretty
much it again it's about I think the one
concern that I have still is because the
location is still kind of not confirmed
and I said yeah yeah I it's not solid
until money has changed hands and then
ultimately that also affects the shoot
date yeah and that is really the only
thing right now because not only are we
trying to shoot in early January so our
other fourteen Alberta productions four
story hives so you know we've already
had and we've already talked to some
actors who are on other story high
projects already which is great but it's
you know we got to think about
scheduling
yeah um I'm stoked I'm excited I I feel
a lot better today than I felt most of
the week things were feeling things were
kind of grim and blue in the world of
Dan up until Friday yeah
Star Wars helped Star Wars helped Star
Wars helped and then doing doing that
minisode about Star Wars and kind of
getting my creative block right yeah out
of the look like you know getting making
something that yeah but do you want to
talk about that do you want to talk
about like well about depression but
also about how that overwhelming
expectation of like something that
really belongs to you in effect yeah
it's well it's really there's a lot of
pressure that I mean and most of it is
being put on me by myself it's my own
expectations and my own perceived
consequences for like if things is that
what if I don't live up to expectations
what if I don't need my expectations
what if things go wrong what if things
go catastrophic leer on and I end up you
know becoming this like you know you you
invent these things whereas like
realistically it's such a like if as
long as I don't you know burn any
bridges then even if it just absolutely
sucks it doesn't matter because if the
only problem is that it like doesn't
quite come together well then I can just
bury it right you know more or less like
I could just it's like all right well
that didn't work
move on so really like the stakes are
super low yeah however playing - what
gift
what what if game is like sick yeah and
and constantly sort of like
second-guessing yourself and it gets
really easy to get worried that like
okay well you know it's now Tuesday
it's mid-december and like well this
isn't locked down and that isn't locked
down and like what if you know what ifs
do you can't find a place what if you
know everything's rented
what if we end up running into just some
massive logistical thing and then it's
you know January 15 and the thing is is
that when you've got that much chaos the
temptation is just to shut down right
and just to lights like oh well here's
all these problems so I'm going to
ignore them and hope they go away
because eventually they will go away on
a long enough timeline everything goes
away someday sighs I the Sun will expand
and will consume the earth erasing all
evidence that any of this ever happened
and take comfort in knowing that
oblivion before that at the end of it
all is oblivion yeah and and no one will
remember what happened that night
that's so it yeah it got kind of got
kind of grim and it led to a pretty you
know sort of rough rough depression the
surge that I was dealing with fros of
the week but I feel like that has passed
doesn't mean it won't come back
hopefully hopefully it doesn't but you
know such is the challenges of making
things well also dealing with you know
personal Oh totally and you know like I
am NOT I am NOT special no no that came
out totally what I mean that is is that
if anything we should start talking
about that more great we're recognizing
that this is the process sometimes yes
right and it shouldn't be frowned upon
as being you know some sort of I don't
know like discrepancy in how things are
made right you know our project isn't
gonna be suffering because of that you
know if anything that's gonna be better
well we were talking this is something
that we were talking about a couple days
ago when we first started the casting
when we first started the auditions was
the you know we were talking about the
schedule and
like oh well you know there's there's a
lot of this anxiety about things not
being firmed down and we have to remind
ourselves that it's like the timeline of
how things are falling into place right
now is ordinary like this is a very sort
of ordinary example of the process of
like oh well you know yeah you've got
your you're a couple weeks away from
shooting but there's still things that
are in flux that's that's routine yeah
like that really is we've seen it over
and over again as much as we want it to
be like we wanted we really want it to
just sort of like charge out the gates
like alright December 3rd we've got our
location on lock December 8th again oh
you know we've got our crew on lock
ready to go yeah and like it's like we
can spend a month polishing that's not
like that's the dream yeah that's not
how it happened actually 9 out of 10
times I think well another aspect of
though that's been frustrating for me in
particular is I know people who have
that experience alright yeah they they
have the context and they have the
locations and they know who to phone and
I don't have any of that so that's been
one of my shortfalls I feel as a
producer I'm just like how am i able to
support Dan with his like the directing
creative aspects when I have nothing to
bring the table in terms of that and of
course that led to the decision to bring
on Steve because we know that he has an
experience so I mean again I hope that
I've been supporting you enough in the
process to get where we are but it's
always been something that I think we've
been really good at it's communicating
that you know when we hadn't lost
production dialogue when I was over
there helping Dan put the script pieces
of them together I didn't go over there
saying okay we're gonna go do this to
show up and dad get down to work in the
what I said and the text is like do you
even want me to help like just focus
your attention towards doing this and I
hope that it was
okay no yeah yes like you the and and
there are absolutely times like when I'm
when I'm working on stuff like when I'm
when I'm cutting or when I'm writing
that there are types of works like know
what I need to do is I need to just
turtle up and do it you know that I'm
not in a place where I can like
emotionally handle trying to navigate
you know the the collaborative process
then there's other times where words
like know I need to collaborate like
right now like I need someone to to like
tell me my ideas are stupid and you know
they're just like yeah right I was about
to say I'm like you turtle up as who
though I mean turtling up as Raphael
look out I don't know if I want to show
up for that that was not what I meant
that's not what I meant but yeah I mean
it's been and I think that's so great
about these production vlogs to you is
it's allowing us to you kind of dissect
our experiences going through this and
again this is new for Dan and I having
the capacity to have the funds available
and ready to go and then finding all the
components to to make it work yeah
that's what I've been finding is the
most alien yeah you know then it's like
oh well we're looking for a location
that we're then going to pay money for
rather than just sending out a Facebook
blast being like hey who's going to let
us take over their living room who's got
a kitchen with an island yeah or just
does everyone got a camera package that
they can just like lend us or or how
about just yourselves and we'll feed you
that's very difficult
yeah but no I think going back to you
know we're in a very
state right now I don't think we're
behind no no and again you know if I
need to email that to you every single
day I'll do that all right yeah
so loss happening it's gonna be very
exciting to pick out who's gonna be in
this film oh and the other component of
that it wasn't just about like the
visuals we actually found some people
who could do the voice-over work for our
stuff yes we were auditioning voices at
the same time yeah
and some of them were like whoa whoa
whoa all right that's funny media is
almost full okay the cards almost fall
same time high five high five